fellas uh let's talk about the movie a
great idea
now uh the movie is called studio six
six six six yeah it's a horse it's a
horror film starring the foo fighters
with many guest appearances i was
looking for a place for us to like demo
music not in the studio maybe rent a
house like just find a house and
coincidentally my landlord from 10 years
ago this house in the movie i lived in
that house 10 years ago while i was
remodeling my place down the street
he's like hey i'm going to sell the
place do you want to buy it i was like
no
but if we could rent it to record some
[ __ ] in there that'd be cool he's like
great so we move in there and we start
demoing stuff and then i was like wait a
second we're in this creepy old house
we could [ __ ] make the record take
two weeks off and then make some really
quick low budget slasher gore [ __ ]
film just for fun so then i came up with
this idea i was like oh you know what
okay foo fighters move into a creepy
house house turns out to be haunted i
become possessed i kill the whole
[ __ ] band and then i go solo that was
the basic premise of the whole thing
and so i thought well that'll be fun you
know all the guys are like yeah why not
with [ __ ] we've been we've done stupider
[ __ ] than that and uh
then all of a sudden it was like then
there's screenwriters then there's a
[ __ ] table read then there's a
[ __ ] special effect and then it
turned into a full-length feature film
and we're just like holy [ __ ] well let
me ask you this because it is a risk and
i'm sure taylor and you had this feeling
you know you're a band with a lot of
credibility and sometimes that can
stifle creativity it's a fun idea on
paper for the foo fighters to go make a
movie and to to do that but you gotta
say to yourself wait we're the foo
fighters people love our music if we
make a [ __ ] shitty movie and if we're
like too goofy in it
we could end up actually being the
monkeys and our music won't be taken
seriously absolutely not yeah you have
to look at the 26 years of those [ __ ]
videos that we've been making we're like
right you know people on the airplane
and if yeah i mean we've it's like if
any band was gonna do this it was gonna
be us and it's that thing where it's i
think people appreciate us
for that side of what we do it's like we
make records we take those really
[ __ ] seriously we go out and we play
shows we take that really [ __ ]
seriously we want to make great songs we
want to be the best live band in the
world everything outside of that it's
like come on like what are we gonna like
are we gonna try to look like this cool
handsome rock band and like yeah we're
like the the saviors of rock and roll
[ __ ] that dude i mean we have so little
time why not why not do it